don't you love college to make youtube
videos so exactly how excited were your
parents about this they were they were
the ones that actually encouraged me to
like personally my dreams and move out
to LA so y know right I had the blessing
of a brown parent you know that don't
have another day my mom actually met in
theater class in college and my dad was
told he would only be like stereotyped
cast as a brown man and so now here I am
being a brown girl doing all the both of
them are like that's not I'd like to say
my sister says I stole her personality
identical so how do you do anything Lisa
so who's like your favorite person
you've ever had on your YouTube channel
lucky enough I had Barack Obama
president what was that like were you
nervous
oh so nervous the man walked into room
he smelled like all types of pumpkin
spice fall candles like he's a dryer
sheett known to man that's what he
smells like oh my god did he blow
himself I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this